I'm Ross Ahmet and we're the Doppler
brothers and we created stranger things
and this is a definitive list of all the
film references and stranger things get
away from her you
so we're huge fans of the Alien
franchise especially alien aliens it
depends on on the year in terms of which
one we think is is better basically
they're both incredible films aliens in
particular really had a big influence on
season two especially when you have the
soldiers go into the underground tunnel
system but all the stuff in terms of
atmospheric effects some of it we were
inspired by in the games on Hill but
some of it was also inspired by what it
was like when they went on the planet
and we're live in Ridley Scott's an
alien and then we even having an egg
there the dimma Gorgon egg which is
inspired by the what they discover on
the planet an alien and that egg was
real and now and it's season one
especially all the spores all the spores
blowing through the air that was all
real we were blowing them around we had
David and Wynonna walking around in
those suits in the forest it was
old-school just blowing these basically
little tiny feathers in their faces it
was a lot of fun for them
oh god please nobody kids police officer
discovers wills body we gave a little
nod to Dan O'Bannon who was the writer
for alien state trooper David O'Bannon
thank you so much for help thank you
as we've said before alien was such a
huge reference for us altered states I
think mostly was an inspiration in terms
of just the experiments that Brenner was
performing on 11 specifically the
isolation think is something we
discussed about that and looked at that
film and when we were building our
isolation tape but it's a trippy trippy
film that could have only been made in
the seventies I think it was 1980 now I
think about it talking about Stephen
King and why his books resonated so much
with us and one of those books of course
was was Carey and Kerry of course you
have a high school girl who has these
amazing powers these amazing abilities
and we always looked at how King dealt
with that when we we've talked about 11
and this idea she's these amazing
abilities but is she ultimately
dangerous especially would she when
she's with these kids and we see her
when she hurts Lucas out in the junkyard
and we sort of sort of seen that these
powers aren't necessarily fully under
her control or that she can lose control
and and when she does she can be
dangerous looking at that as a girl with
these powers who's unable to fit into
society you know it was a real big
touchstone for us the two Stephens are
the biggest influence for us so we've
talked a little bit out Stephen King and
then there's Steven Spielberg who you
may have heard of there was a lot of
imagery in season two that evoke Close
Encounters of the Third Kind
particularly the sequence where a Berry
is connect that was the sequence when we
were kids and we saw Close Encounters
for the first time that kind of stayed
with us the most so when will is first
getting signals from the upside down and
episode one and he hears thunder outside
he opens that door that's a pretty
direct homage to Close Encounters and we
do an homage hood this year with Dustin
when his toy sort of all go out of
control and stuff I mean he realizes
ultimately that it's just 11
manipulating it but that was definitely
nod towards it and then and that was all
all those toys were so we had every toy
it was on a remote control and it was
one of those things or you know they're
about ten toys there's ten remotes and
you figure it's gonna be absolute
disaster and it actually worked out it's
really every hiding spot behind sofa
beds closets there was someone with a
remote control and they were all trying
to get these things all work together it
was actually when it worked it was it
was really miraculous and the last thing
about Close Encounters I will say it's
also you know it's said in Indiana and
that was a big touchstone for us when we
were deciding where to set the show so
it was things like Close Encounters and
Breaking Away
that really inspired us as kids growing
up so we felt that was a great
everywhere USA
kind of location
[Music]
Kujo
we obviously referenced that in season
one I think we have it we have one of
the guards and Hawkins lab reading Cujo
they had a really nice big picture of
Stephen King on the back and we thought
that was a way of tipping our hat to the
king of course not obvious enough that
we owed him a debt we try to make it
more obvious than that in that shot
that's right and then in season two we
have some demo dogs who's kind of a new
creature so big big bad dogs so they're
a little bit Cujo they're a little bit
the dogs from ghostbusters but big bad
scary dogs are always fun et was a big
film for us going up as it was for a lot
of kids it was like mildly traumatizing
but you know is a huge influence on us
in terms of the opening scene of
stranger things is you know our kids
playing Dungeons and Dragons and eating
pizza and that's their you know I was
gonna see mini t where the kids are
playing D&D and but the idea of
basically a kid in a relatable suburban
setting who encounters something
extraordinary the feeling that that gave
us as kids is the feeling that we wanted
to capture with the show and then in
Episode three in season one we have the
kids also trying to dress up 11 to make
her seem like a normal girl which was a
nod to when they really try to and they
dress up et to try to make me et fit in
and then in season two of courses our
Halloween season et cetera Halloween so
we've looked at that for inspiration in
terms of the costumes that all the kids
were wearing is they sort of went out
and went out
[Music]
when we pitch this to Netflix we cut
together a little reel that you know
included some of the movies we love just
to get across a tone and also it was
score to John Carpenter music so that
sort of always been our go-to in sort of
what the sound the show can sound like
in season two in Episode seven
when eleven ends up going to Chicago and
meeting up with her sister we use one of
his scores from Escape from New York we
attempt with it and we just we said this
that this has got to go in the show
because it just fits too perfect
[Music]
firestarters a was a big reference
specifically for 11 in the case that
you've got a young girl that has these
incredible powers she's on the run from
the government and we also looked at
fire start in terms of sort of the
backstory 411 and how she can how how
she could possibly get these powers so
we needed something visual that would
represent what 11 using her powers you
know when she when she uses her ability
she gets a nosebleed and that was
something we settled on very early on
that we thought would very simply tell
the audience each time she's used these
powers Frankenstein was a reference in
and we included it in episode 2 of
season 2 when Elevens at home alone and
she's watching and the reason we want to
include that um reason we've talked
about Frings and writing this is that
this is just that xi is feeling like the
Frankenstein's monster and that she's
feeling isolated and alone and she feels
different from everyone else and just
cut off and she feels like a monster and
so that's why we wanted her to be
watching that film in episode I mean
episode 2 Ghostbusters is one of our
favorite films of all time III I mean we
watched it way too many times as
children so it's it's all over the show
it's one of the one you know we gave
them pretty probably the most direct
reference to Ghostbusters in season two
when we obviously have the kids dress up
as Ghostbusters come you're trying to
figure out whether you're gonna wear for
Halloween one of them was gonna always
be a Ghostbusters and then someone was
like why aren't they all just
Ghostbusters they can either each be a
Ghostbusters and that so that was so fun
dressing up all of our kids and also
these characters in deciding who would
be human the week you know we just
argued about in the room and being like
everyone would want to be Venkman and
that's and that sort of led to the the
Venkman argument why are you thinking
because I'm thinking no I'm thinking why
can't there just be two increments
because there's only one Vikrant in real
life we planned this months ago
[Music]
gremlins is first of all one of our
favorite films growing up and he was
also a big reference particularly in
season two of the show with dart which
like gizmo Begins is this sort of loving
creature that Dustin was trying to take
care of anything and he starts to
actually care for this cute little thing
and then of course we realized that it's
anything but it's a baby gimmick organ
and I think there's a scene in episode 3
I believe where dart is starting to crow
and escapes and the kids are trying to
attack it and go after it and we we had
our composer sort of do a little theme
that sounded like a little bit like the
original gremlins theme because we just
wanted to give it a little we're big
Indiana Jones fans we are big fans of
Temple of Doom and specifically we
referenced it I think it was in season 2
the episode 9 the the final episode of
season 2 when we have max driving
Billy's car and she's got a block on the
pedal just like shortround has to use a
block in order to drive the car and
Temple of Doom when they make their
escape remember a production designer
theme like Sadie doesn't need a block
she can reach that and the way when we
were so devastating because we wanted to
give that little nod but then we put
samey in the car and she could not reach
the pedal I'm sure now she could but
luckily in season 2 she couldn't so we
got our we got our block in there I was
like Indiana Jones himself you know it's
a big reference for hopper we always we
talked to David about Harrison Ford
probably more than anything else and
trying to just sort of capture that
energy that's one reason we have hopper
punching people all the time because
Indiana Jones punches people all the
time
David was upset because in season two he
didn't get to punch anybody and so in
season three there's a ton of hopper
bunching people David is really good at
capturing the the Harrison Ford
Addison's now many modern actors are
able to do it aside from Harrison Ford
of course who is the one and only in a
no Jones there can be no more that's
right the opening scene of
we include something Horrible's having
just some scientists that we were
inspired by the ending of Raiders of the
Lost Ark where they open the Ark in it
just causes these horrific things to
happen in that just seared itself into
her brain so we wanted to give a little
knot and a little nod to that like
sometimes I'm more in the mood to watch
Last Crusade dead the banter between
Sean Sean Connery and Harrison Ford and
it's just it's it's very similar to
Raiders of course but it's just got a
little bit of a is it got a little bit
of a different tone if you just learn
how to make a film I mean just watch
Raiders I mean every scene is a
masterclass it really is Nightmare on
Elm Street it was a huge film for us
growing up it really scared us but we
couldn't help but keep watching it
episode 3 in season 1 when holly goes up
to the wall and you can see the demo
board in moving from behind the wall
which is very similar to win you see
Freddy Krueger coming out of the wall
above Nancy's been in Nightmare on Elm
Street but it's right because in
nightmare industry they tried they did
that practically that effective Krueger
coming through the wall with latex and
that's what we attempted to do and
failed we basically had our demo our
monster a guy in a suit pressing him his
face and hands through the wall and it
wasn't particularly scary we had a
little toddler on set playing Holly and
she thought it was amusing which was a
sign that it wasn't exactly working so
we got to enhance it quite a bit with CG
and post-production so if we were
especially season 1 determined to do
everything practically and I think maybe
it was like a 50% success rate but it
makes you more impressed about in terms
of or more blown away by what they were
able to achieve back then
[Music]
well Steven Keens huge influence on the
show we actually first experienced it
when we saw the miniseries back in 1990
so we were around six or seven way too
young for this thing we already were
deathly scared of clowns and that just
pushed it over the edge couldn't sleep
for a couple weeks like the most scared
I've ever been in my life it's an
incredible book just really about these
kids and and their friendship and how by
you know working together uniting and
through their the strength of their
friendship they're able to overcome this
incredible interdimensional evil so
without it I'm you know they're you know
there really wouldn't be no stranger
things probably we have to name a
favorite film we usually lean on jaws
because I think it does to us everything
that we love love about cinema it has
great characters comedy yeah spectacle
it's about a chief of the chief of
police small town in a small town where
something out of the ordinary happens so
it's a big influence I mean we have
hoppers car is very much very closely
inspired by chief Brody's car and also
in season three you know we've been
wanting a Larry Larry Vaughan as the
mayor in Jaws and we've been wanting a
Larry Vaughan character every year and
we've never just had room and we finally
have room this year for it so Cary Elwes
who's just incredible is coming and sort
of taking on this part of Mayor that's
very much inspired by that word that
someone who is much more concerned about
his doing well for himself and he is
necessarily about the well-being of the
town whenever we were talking about the
Dimmick organ in season one he was very
much influenced by the shark in Jaws
because we wanted it to be a shark like
creature except instead of coming out
from under the water he was coming out
from another dimension so that was a
who'd break through the surface of that
dimension reaching to ours grab a victim
like bar for instance and pulled that
victim back into his world
sit over the underwater it's the
upside-down
[Music]
John Hughes you know was a big influence
in all of his hills or really it's just
something that's about these sort of
outcasts that are coming together and
and you know they have all these
differences but at the end of the day
they end up realizing that they have
more in common than they thought and
that sort of character development is
something we talk about when we're
working on the show when we were working
on season two or developing a season two
we always knew we wanted to end at the
snowball which is an idea that we had
introduced at the end of it end of
season one and so we always knew that
that was going to be the ending of
season two it feels like at least 50% or
more of the classic teen 80s films
feature some sort of massive dance where
everything goes down John Hughes is
especially a master of that and so we
wanted to pay pay homage to that this
year we have a new character who he's
working with at the mall which is Robin
played by Mike Hawk and so the whole
vibe there in the mall is very John
Hughes and that we have a bunch of
characters kind of forced to work
together who normally would not
associate with
[Music]
we saw Jurassic Park in theaters and I
just remember it just blew our minds
just in terms of the spectacle the
dinosaurs were just so incredible and
they and they honestly still are it
holds up so well and Jurassic Park is
referenced or was a reference for us in
season two is particularly episode eight
when our characters are stuck in Hawkins
lab and they have to escape and bob has
to go and sort of you know he's to go
and reset the power in order for them to
get out which is very similar to when
some more dirt has to sort of follow a
map power going back on in Jurassic Park
it goes better for Laura Dern though it
than it did for Bob
unfortunately for Bob and then also
season season three it's a pretty big
reference we have a lot we have some
hiding sequences with the children this
year that is it was very much inspired
by the classic kitchen same interesting
Park where they're hiding from those
rafters we watch that over and over
again I mean I think it's one it's you
know one of the best suspense sequences
in film history which is when the kids
are hiding from the rafters in the
kitchen incredible filming and you can
learn everything you need to know about
directing suspense from watching this
[Music]
we're big man max fans so when this new
kid max comes into town we figured she'd
likely be a Mad Max fan as well and like
Max she's an outsider that sort of
coming into this community so we felt
that it applied to her character and
that this is someone that feels very
different than the others and she's
really an outcast and then ultimately
she ends up of course bonding with a
script and becoming a hero and then
driving like a badass driving and
driving like Mel Gibson risky business
first of all if you haven't seen risky
business you know it's a great film it's
kind of weirdly dark 80's film in season
2 it's one of our more direct references
of course again Steve and Nancy arrived
at their Halloween party dressed as the
characters from risky business
which also work because it was all white
when we wanted it to when she spills the
punch to be to be a very dramatic event
so that all white outfit really worked
out for us
[Music]
scanners is a great film and it was a
reference for us particularly in terms
of weapon powers on Episode seven of
season one where she she sort of makes
the government agents and mines melt
it's not as grotesque and scanners I
don't think Netflix would have loved it
and we had blown their heads up but that
was our version of it without gay into
too big spoiler territory we definitely
go that Cronenberg in sees a huge and
when we were taping sound I remember we
couldn't quite get the right exploding
sound so for the temp sound we when we
just took it from scanner it was the
best explosion sound we could find still
[Music]
stand by me it's one of our favorite
films we saw when we were really young I
remember being a big deal because we
were watching an r-rated movie which we
weren't allowed to watch a lot of our
babies cursed
because they just cursed though it was
our parents team it was okay deemed
appropriate and I thought we should
watch it and I'm really glad they let us
watch it um you know Stand By Me is
based on novella by Stephen King called
the body it's not a coincidence that we
named episode for season one the body
sort of a most direct nod to it is when
we have well in season one and two we
have character sort of walking down
these these train tracks which is you
know that was it was a big part of stand
by me as they were following the trains
as the body so that's probably our most
or most direct homage to that to that
classic
we actually when we were auditioning our
kids we have an audition with scenes
from that film I think a lot of our kids
hadn't seen stand by me and we that was
a homework assignment for them that they
had a watch stand by me
[Music]
embarrass trikes back is uh I mean we go
back and forth whether we like that or a
new hope a sort of like alien aliens it
depends a day of the week but it was a
big film for us growing up and first of
all eleven powers can be seen as horse
like and that's why we have Mike showing
her the the Yoda figurine in his room in
Episode two we're all on Maple Street
hey the boys are obviously huge Star
Wars fans as they would be at that time
and so it Dustin feels he's being
someone's being a trainer he refers to
them as Lando which is obviously a
reference to Empire as well Leto
Calrissian and then also we always saw
episode 7 of season two is sort of
eleven going to Ortega LA and seen her
Yoda which was a you know sort of from
in this experience gaining some sort of
enhancement of our powers that allows
her to defeat this evil so you know her
especially moving the Train or you know
it's it's it's very much evokes Luke
trying to pull his point
[Music]
super8 so a lot like our show it was
paying homage and and trying to capture
the spirit of these films that we we
grew up loving we have a scene in season
2 episode 6 I believe when they're in
the kids are hiding in in the bus and
then the demo dogs are attacking it
which is similar to a scene in super 8
when they're um they're also hiding the
bus from the giant monster so coming
from and one of the boys in super 8 uses
firecrackers to fight this fight the
monster without giving away too much the
kids may or may not employ fireworks to
their advantage in season 3 the Evil
Dead is one of those movies that we saw
when we were way too young you know it's
a pretty funny movie actually but you
know when you're that young that humor
is completely lost you know we just
thought it was straight-up terrifying
I'm trying to think like specifically
what we referenced well it's the poster
oh yeah Jonathan has the poster up in
his room which his deadbeat dad
disapproves up but we felt like Jonathan
would be someone who would like this
because you know was an independent film
at the time it was it was still it was
pretty uh pretty extreme back then as it
is still now and so we felt though that
Jonathan is this outcast would be
someone would love love evil that I'm
not sure how he saw it actually but you
know he found a way
[Music]
Eamon well The Exorcist obviously if
you're gonna have any sort of evil child
that is the go to go to film and so in
season two when we have will possess you
know certainly you know his head doesn't
spin around but we did try to capture a
little bit of that hearing is that you'd
feel from Linda Blair
and we'll afford it he'll you know he
likes a cold the mind flavor likes it
called Regan and in The Exorcist I mean
it's it gets over the course that film
against the temperature in that house
yes it gets increasingly cold the fog
was a big reference for us in terms of
specifically in terms of the music score
we cut together a trailer for Netflix to
help sell the show we used a track from
the fog this year there's a very fog
like scene in season three in game too
spoilery I hope but you see Billy in the
upside down and he sees some figures
coming towards him out of the fog who
those figures are you help to watch The
Goonies The Goonies I remember I mean
when we first watched a Goonies and we
were kids we immediately just hit rewind
on the VHS and watch it again and
obviously she's sort of the energy that
the kids have in the camaraderie was it
was it's a big touchstone frozen yeah
and specifically I think was probably
more overtly referenced in season two
and we had you know in in the final
episode season nine when when they go
all go down into the tunnel together it
feels a lot like The Goonies going
underground in search of their treasure
it's a little bit of a darker take on
that but it was a big reference and of
course we had you know when it did the
lead of the Goonies was Sean Astin who
you know we cast in season two as Bob
which was you know a real treat for us
so to have a grown up Sean Astin in our
film and he in fact references something
as a as a treasure map don't you get it
it's not possible it's a map it's a map
of Hawkins so little little nod to his
role in the Goonies and Sean was all
about doing it
I'll be back
we're big fans I'm sure there's a
surprise in the Terminator franchise in
the vast minority in that that I've
heard the original Terminator 2 T 2 I'm
gonna get some hate for that Arnold
sapanta Arnold I like Arnall as a bad
guy
and so very much we wanted to have our
own Arnold this year in season 3 and we
found the most incredible Arnold
look-alike but he also captures very
much the spirit of Arnold and I wish I
could talk about the character more
without spoiling things but I can't that
just we have a terminator s character
who is not a robot however there's not
like some twist that he's a robot that
would be yeah so the thing is one of our
favorite movies I think we started a
little bit later like I think we were in
high school cuz that all the movie books
had talked about how this wasn't a good
movie which just blows my mind you know
specifically especially season 3 just in
terms of that we have again I don't want
to get to spoiling but the monster or
monsters this season are sort of
inspired by the monster work that they
didn't know the thing in terms of that
it's certainly our grossest season yet
and that's one thing we we didn't love
about the thing which is just sort of
how grotesque it is and there's actually
a dialogue seen between the kids in
season 3 where they discuss the merits
of what is better the Howard Hawks the
thing the original thing from the 50s or
John Carpenter's remake it's like
carpenters d'they the original is the
classic no question about it but the
remake
we also of course season 2 we have the
flamethrower element and the fact that
this thing doesn't it doesn't react well
to flame that the creatures react
negatively to fire I mean that was a big
element and in the thing and there's
nothing cooler really than Kurt Russell
with a flamethrower to show our love and
affection for the thing we have the boys
in the basement mike has a poster of the
thing and mr. Clark is when they call
him oh yeah they figure out about the
how to create their own sort of
isolation tank mr. Clark of course is
watching the thing with his girlfriend
and and trying to explain how they
created these effects in the first place
using and Matt and I are just still you
know we love to research that stuff
because it really is mind-blowingly
thank you tell me everything you saw
witness so it's weird so so not
everything we references you know is a
genre film and so we're huge fans the
the director Peter Weir but there there
was a scene with Harrison Ford and the
police station when a little boy in the
police station points at a picture of
ultimate murderer who happens to be
actually a cop who works with Harrison
Ford's character we had a sort of very
similar scene by coincidence where
eleven sees the photo of will wall in
Mike's room and points at it and we
really weren't quite sure how to shoot
the scene and we really looked at
witness and how Peter Weir shot that
scene and and he he used a lot of you
know of zooming camera and at that point
before then we hadn't really used the
zoom because we were worried about it
being too cheesy or cliche but after we
shot that scene we loved how it turned
out and we now kind of embraced the zoom
thanks wired so that has been each and
every movie reference industry a lot of
them 70 percent 80 percent
you
[Music]